new rule
don't make me be and i told you so again
you know i was a young man of 59 when i
started using the term slow moving coup
and it pains me to have to report it's
still moving
a document came to light a few weeks ago
called the eastman memo which was
basically a blueprint prepared for trump
on how he could steal the election after
he lost it in november 2020. it outlined
a plan for overturning the election by
claiming that seven states actually had
competing state slates of electors which
well not even remotely true
would have given mike pence the excuse
to throw out those states and thus hand
the election to trump
but of course the plan required election
officials in those states to go along
trump thought the ones who were
republican would
most did not
and that's what he's been working on
fixing ever since
no
not a good thing
not a good thing fixing on
i'll finish
some presidents spend their
post-presidency building homes for the
poor or raising money for charity or
painting their toes
trump has spent his figuring out how to
pull off the coup he couldn't pull off
last time
here's the easiest three predictions in
the world trump will run in 2024
he will get the republican nomination
and whatever happens on election night
the next day he will announce that he
won
i've been saying ever since he lost he's
like a shark that's not gone just gone
out to sea
but actually he's been quietly eating
people this whole time
and by eating people i mean he's been
methodically purging the republican
party of anyone who voted for his
impeachment or doesn't agree that he's
the rightful leader of the seven
kingdoms
yes we're going to need a bigger boat
there was a grand total of 10 republican
congressmen who voted to impeach trump
and by 2024 even those will all be gone
one of them was liz cheney arch
conservative
daughter of darth vader
and yet now politically dead in wyoming
another of the ten was anthony gonzalez
he's already bowed out for running for
reelection because he can see
opposing trump means you have no chance
the other eight will either like him not
run or they'll get primaried by a
trumper or they'll have a sudden
epiphany about how come to think of it
trump did win that election
the purge is also at work in republican
legislatures as several states are
already in the process of changing
election laws so that they
not parted nonpartisan election
officials are in charge of certifying
the results
two weeks after the 2020 election trump
famously called the republican in charge
of elections in georgia secretary of
state brad rafsenberger and told him he
just needed to find
an additional 11 000 trump votes
rafsenberger refused
but he's not going to be there next time
of the 15 republicans running for
secretary of state in the key
battleground states
only two concede that biden won that
election
these are the people trump is going to
call on in 2024 when he's a few votes
short and these people are going to give
it to him
so here's what's going to happen
2022 the midterms republicans win big
why
because the out of power party always
does in a country where the electorate
can't think past throw the bums out
so the republicans take back the house
where disputed elections are decided
and the speaker is kevin mccarthy a man
with all the backbone of one of those
inflatable tube men outside a car
dealership
republicans will also have more key
governors wisconsin pennsylvania and
michigan all had democratic governors
who protected the vote in 2020 but
they're all up for re-election in 22
at least two will lose
2023 trump announces his candidacy and
starts having large rallies across the
country which become increasingly angry
and threatening
as trump indulges his love for inciting
violence
knock the crap out of him they'd be
carried out on a stretcher folks thrown
the hell out like to punch him in the
face
you know i know the hitler analogy is
over the top in many ways it is i don't
think trump hates jews there are too
many rich ones
and i don't think committing genocide is
in his future but the mentality of how
to take over a country is exactly the
same
play on this feeling of we have been
cheated robbed betrayed and now we're
going to take it back
two-thirds of republicans believe the
election was stolen
21 million believe force is justified to
restore trump to office a majority
want to secede
whatever the hell that would entail
and yet
2024 comes
and democrats treat it as a normal
election year they are living in a dream
world where their choice of candidate
matters their policies matter the number
of votes they get matters none of it
does
i won't even predict who the democratic
nominee will be because it doesn't
matter it could be biden
it could be harris it could be amy
klomosher could be timothy chalamet
as long as they have a d by their name
they will be portrayed as the leader of
the army of satan
but even if they win trump won't accept
it but this time his claims
of illegal voting by immigrants or
mail-in ballots coming in after the
deadline or the system was hacked by
venezuela or whatever giuliani comes up
with on the fly
they will be fully embraced by the
stooges he's installing right now
december 16 2024
this is the day electors gather to vote
for president
arizona and wisconsin both send a slate
of bogus trump electors setting up a
showdown on january 6th and daring
kamala harris to do what trumpers wanted
mike pence to do throw out election
results
the difference being this time those
results really are phony and this time
it's not just 600 diabetic fox news
junkies and a nut and a viking helmet
10 million trump voters have signed a
pledge to come to washington
of course not in a half million flake
but half a million still show up and
they're heavily armed and incensed when
harris does what mike pence wouldn't
demonstrations grow in the streets
the kind of antifa versus proud boy
violence we've seen in portland erupts
across the country people are afraid to
go out anywhere where their political
tribe isn't in the majority which hurts
commerce
the stock market is spooked by the
unrest in tumbles as inauguration day
approaches
president biden is under extraordinary
pressure to do something to stop the
coup before his authority over the
military and the justice department
evaporates at noon on january 20th
what happens when two presidential
candidates show up on inauguration day
both expecting to be sworn in like a bad
sitcom pilot
the ding dongs who sacked the capital
last year
that was like when al qaeda tried to
take down the world trade center the
first time with a van
it was a joke
but the next time they came back with
planes
i hope i scared the out of you
thank you very much that's our show
we're off next week and back on the 22nd
you